it's a keeper all the way makes a cut  dash is free and look out caleb williams  in the secondary  they're trying to run him down  dives  touchdown oklahoma  66 yards on fourth and a foot  forget that play last week  with that we just said what this guy's  gonna bring to the table eventually  he's watched the foot come down  where the foot comes down it's not the  shoulder right there he's inbounds and  in the elbow but that left foot touched  to get him in bounds watch this a  progressive pylon cam  check this foot out  oh my god goodness oh my gosh he's  inbound  direct snap brooks trying to make  something happen he breaks free  forget the field goal whatever